تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا تعرضت
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كياف لهجوم عنيف حيث
اعلن عمده المدينه ان الشخصين قتل واصيب
اخرون في هجوم صاروخي روسي هذا بقاله
الاداره العسكريه لمقاطع الهجوم بدا
بالمسيرات من الاتجاهات المختلفه وتبعه
هجوم بالصواريخ واضافت ان القوات الجويه
دمرت 20 هدفا في اجواء العاصمه في حين
افادت قياده القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه بان
روسيا اطلقت مجموعتين من المسيرات الاولى
باتجاه كييف والاخرى باتجاه وسط وجنوب
البلاد تبعهما اطلاق صواريخ كروز من
قاذفات استراتيجيه ومن السفن الحربيه في
البحر الاسود باتجاه ست مناطق مختلفه
مع ذلك افادت وسائل الاعلام روسيه بتعارض
مقاطعات عده غرب البلاد لهجوما واسع
بمسيارات اوكرانيه ليله الماضيه واكد حاكم
مقاطعه بيسكوف ان القوات الروسيه صادت
هجوما اوكرانيا بمسيارات استهدف مطار
المدينه هذا ونقلت وكاله عن مصادر في
اجهزه الطوارئ ان الهجوم اسفر عن تضرر
اربع طائرات عسكريه واضافت ان الحركه
الجويه فوق المقاطعه تم تقييدها من جانبه
اعلن حاكم مقاطعه اوريا الاسقاطا مسيرتين
اوكرانيتين فوق المقاطعه كما اكدت سلطات
مقاطعه بريانز واكالوجا ورزانس وموسكو
اسقاط مسيرات اوكرانيه عده هذا واعلن حاكم
مدينه صفا اسطبل في شبه جزيره القرم عن
تصدي الدفاعات الجويه لهجوم الاوكراني
بالمسيرات من جهتها قالت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان طائراتها دمرت اربعه قوارب
سريعه على متنها نحو 50 عنصر من القوات
الخاصه الاوكرانيه في حوض البحر الاسود
ما في تعليقها على الهجمات قالت الخارجيه
الروسيه ان محاوله اوكرانيا مهاجمه
الاراضي الروسيه بطائرات من دون طيار دليل
على وصول كييف الى طريق مسدود حسب تعبيرها
واضافت الخارجيه الروسيه ان ما سمتها
معاناه نظام كياف والكراهيه وغياب اي افق
لتنميته ادت الى مواصفاته بالنشاط
الارهابي